invasive species in their native
habitats they live in balance with
nature's food chain but in foreign
territory they can become dangerous
intruders now there's a new invader on
the block a ferocious fish with a
massive appetite and razor-sharp teeth
it may even walk on land the snakehead
it represents a an introduction of
something that can compete and possibly
out-compete the native fishes a northern
snakehead reaches sexual maturity by age
2 or 3 each spawning each female can
release up to 15,000 eggs at once snake
heads can mate as often as five times a
year
this means in just two years a single
female can release up to a hundred and
fifty thousand eggs in a natural habitat
where predators and prey work in balance
fast readings kept in check but in a
foreign ecosystem where natural
predators are missing it can lead to a
disastrous population explosion snake
heads are also known to lash out at any
who approached them of the 29 known
snakehead varieties many like the giant
snakehead
are powerful hunters with ravenous
appetites
and sharp snapping jaws jaws that can
tear flesh
flash never know how you got don't know
what movie at first I wasn't quite sure
with baby I saw a lot of blood on my arm
Cody I thought it was much more pigment
hurt me that much they can fight your
entire hand off in the US snakehead
attacks are just a small part of their
danger to an ecosystem invading snake
heads pose a far greater threat outside
its natural habitat the northern variety
can decimate a food chain
these fish are top-level predators that
will eat virtually anything in their
path they can travel across land and
live out of water for up to three days
on land snakehead use a primitive lung
above their gills they have these air
chambers just up underneath the the
skull so they'll rise to the surface go
bear that air is forced up into those
air chambers which act in many respects
like a lung to complete this monstrous
picture
some say the snakehead can do something
few other fish can walk on land
out of the water snakeheads rhythmically
moved their fins and muscular bodies
back and forth it's the fish equivalent
of walking and if snake ends do in fact
use this ability to cover distances
above water
it's a resourceful adaptation walking on
land and mean the difference between
as the Battle of man versus snakehead
continuous biologists and fishermen
reviewing sit back and wait
they monitor population growth study DNA
and gather as much information as
possible hoping to find a clue to the
best way to control this Frankenfish
only time will tell how dangerous this
foreign predator is the ecosystem but
one thing's clear if the snakehead has
already earned the title of an
unforgettable to Stella